[Music]
why was a man convicted of assaulting
his wife and child able to purchase a
semi-automatic weapon and other firearms
legally in America devon patrick kelly
massacred 26 people with those guns on
sunday the US Air Force now admitting it
failed to enter his court-martial
conviction into a database used in
background checks authorities in Texas
confirmed today Kelly wasn't in the
system there was nothing in our
databases have precluded him from
purchasing firearms he is not in any FBI
database we have not had any
investigations on him previous to this
event
we also learned today that Kelly escaped
from a mental health facility in 2012
the massacre has stirred up yet another
debate about gun control in America it
expanded all the way out to South Korea
today where the president was asked this
I wonder if you would consider extreme
betting for people trying to buy a gun
you know you're bringing up a situation
that probably shouldn't be discussed too
much right now we could let a little
time go by but it's okay if you feel
that that's an appropriate question even
though we're the heart of South Korea if
you did what you're suggesting there
would have been no difference three days
ago
and you might not have had that very
brave person who happened to have a gun
or a rifle in his truck go out and shoot
him and hit him and neutralize him not
gonna help okay Gregg get your thoughts
on and comments on the president's
remarks and also the call of the
question that's always the the debate
you're gonna get in both sides good guy
with a gun
bad guy with a gun there are far more
good guys out there then there are bad
guys
that's why science it's common sense
that you hope that there are more good
guys out there and you and you have them
trained and we'll talk about that later
but I want to take this whole thing in
this entirety this guy fractured an
infant's skull he escaped from a mental
hospital he beat up a puppy these are
all markers of the kind of person who
should not be allowed to have weapons
this guy was caught sneaking firearms
into his air base he was attempting to
carry out death threats again
his chain of command we are told to see
something and say something nobody did
anything how did this guy get a gun this
is the last creature on earth that this
is this is a mistake that rivals Fort
Hood 26 lives are dead because somebody
dropped the ball this is exactly like
Nidal Hasan they knew that this was a
bad egg and they didn't do anything
would they tell us when you see
something say something but that nobody
does anything because nobody wants to
get in trouble and maybe this was just a
mistake
but this is a huge mistake it costs 26
lakh awful and when you see the rest of
the news and developments that have
occurred in this case say no when you
see escaped from a mental facility you
know beats animals fractured his
stepsons skull beat his wife I mean it's
just horrific this is exactly the type
of person that shouldn't be allowed to
have any weapon to do further harm it's
like the grey said showing tendencies of
what you look at classically for like
serial killer and boatman President
Trump
two days ago I guess now in Asia he
talked about it being a mental health
issue but now this is actually a
criminal issue and so then when there
are cries of do something well do
something would be not necessarily
passed new laws but how about just
enforce the laws that are on the books
senator Cornyn today actually had to
introduce legislation that said hey tell
you what it'd be a great idea if
everybody that has information on
criminal convictions could upload that
to the background check system how about
we do that I mean if that doesn't pass
by a voice vote tomorrow that's an
outrage
totally Jesse I'm you know now more
times passed since the the horrific
murders of these innocent lives and
we're learning more you know about this
man about the killer
about his background and about where the
system you know failed these families
yeah the air force has blood on its
hands and all they had to do was do
their job and they failed and the
Inspector General is now launching an
investigation the Air Force is a great
institution saves countless lives
patrolling the skies but they lost two
dozen this week so the guy fractures an
infant's skull chokes his girlfriend
beats her with his hands kicks her in
the belly and it's only a misdemeanor
that's wrong on the start of it so
second of all the judge and his name
as J Wesley more very soft sentence
one-year lockup it should have been five
years now if he had served five years
which was the minimum for doing
something like this he would have still
been locked up and wouldn't not been
able to go on the shooting spree and the
12-month confinement automatically
triggers no handgun or a rifle purchases
so why was it a bad conduct just just
charge instead of a dishonorable
discharge if it was dishonorable which
it was beating infants and women that
should have again triggered a ban on
purchasing weapons and then if you you
know caught escaping from a mental
facility that's obviously this guy's a
total maniac so they're already gun
control laws and legal remedies in place
to prevent this guy from purchasing a
weapon but because of human error and
bad judgment
this guy was allowed to go on a rampage
and then for the media to say that this
is all about gun control I mean that's
like shooting first asking questions
later and if the answer is more gun
control they're asking the wrong
questions there were already gun control
laws in place so they're so out of touch
especially this woman up there asking
the president a question so out of touch
with the American people to ask some
point something like that it really
makes me angry
the media's reaction of the recent
tragedies if you just look at has been
so off-base the Las Vegas shooter what
was the reaction there banned silencers
what did that have to do with anything
how about the NYC terror attack they're
talking about Islamophobia and then you
remember what happened with the
Hurricanes they're talking about
milania's heels and global warming it's
no wonder they get the moniker of fake
news mm-hmm all right but that was
well-prepared Jesse I do feel better
afternoon he does all right so one the
couple of issues here obviously the gun
control debate
like we said taking center stage here
you also have then the president's
reaction dealing with this issue while
he's overseas on a trip and being asked
and what are your thoughts on that well
first I think the president and I said
to me to say but I think so many
conservatives just have a kind of
knee-jerk reaction which is we're not
going to talk about this not the best
time
to talk about it it's too soon after the
tragedy or I'm overseas or I'm busy but
I don't want to talk about it and so
that's what it comes off as but I think
you know I just wanted to respond to
something Jesse said I don't think the
media is out of touch when they asked
the question of the President of the
United States Jesse it's like 80% of
Americans think we should have universal
background checks and when I'm listening
to my colleagues here this afternoon I
think you guys really are making a case
that if someone has a history of mental
disturbance a history of criminal
behavior we as an American people should
know about it and we should be able to
impose some limits on their ability to
access there was a mistake no but I'm
saying this is not but this is not a
question anymore I mean this is why I
was so pleased with Jesse yesterday when
Jesse said well we can't agree totally
on gun control cos you you want you want
gun control Jesse says he doesn't but we
can't agree that certain people who are
criminals mentally deranged should not
be able to get guns and yet the Congress
does nothing No okay you know what could
be done and and we talked about locking
up people there is a missing remedy here
and that is institutionalization when
you have a maniac and a monster we have
no place to put them over the last 50
years we've seen a decline of 95 percent
in state-run institutions we house under
50,000 people who are dangerously or
mentally ill and we don't that's about
it is a 95 percent drop when you factor
in the doubling of the population of the
general population we don't have a place
to put these people long term because
we've made that a toxic decision we've
made the idea of institutionalization is
wrong when in fact it saves lives and it
would have saved this lot lives if this
guy was in a permanent situation or
semi-permanent there were a number of
fails that resulted in 26 lives losses
and horrific injuries now last nigh to
strangers who banded together to stop
the deranged gunman embraced at a vigil
for the victims emotional images of
Steven Willeford and Jonny Lang and Dorf
hugging one another Villa Ford is
credited with firing the shots that
chased off the shooter he insists he's
not a hero
though many feel otherwise I'm no hero
I am NOT I think my God my Lord
protected me and gave me the skills to
do what needed to be done and I just
wish I could have gotten there faster
but I didn't know I didn't know what was
happening all right Greg just real quick
and we'll take it around these your time
to come as the president was making
though saying thank God that some was
armed and stood up when you see an act
of heroism you question whether you can
do that the answer is yes you can do
that if you are trained because when
you're trained it's a reflex action it's
born of training this is the first and
only time that he has ever been in this
situation and he responded to the
situation perfectly why because he was
he was an nra certified he was trained
in this we talked about the solution of
hardening soft targets you hardens soft
targets through the training of
individuals in Israel when there are
terror attacks they advise citizens
there to arm their houses because there
are people with knives that come to
their houses they train the population
to respond to threats that was a man who
didn't have to think and that's why he
responded heroically that's why even
though he was terrified it was ingrained
in his skull of what to do unbelievable
and that's the makes the case it makes
the point for proper training and
education arming yourself with the
information about weapons as well good
dinner and also I think what he's
talking about is his faith and how his
faith guided him he doesn't think of
himself as a hero obviously we're all
going to disagree with that but I can
understand where he's coming from he's
he is saying I had this capability in
these towns because God had provided
that to me and he had me there at the
right place at the right time and I wish
that I could have done more and it's not
easy to talk about your faith especially
when it will be ridiculed by so many and
so I just I I admire him for being
willing not only to talk about that
terrible day but to share with America
and the world that he actually believes
that it was God that was guiding him
yeah a very impactful lesson Jesse when
he talks about his faith guiding him and
given the courage and that he had the
wherewithal and also the training right
be able to jump into action and I said
that the media was out of touch wand
because they were bash in the NRA
and guess what as you would like to say
it was an NRA train member who ended up
saving lives that day also at a touch
because they're calling for more gun
control yet I think three gun control
laws were broken and not enforced it's
not about having more gun control we
already have great gun control in this
country but people didn't enforce it
people were sloppy
and a judge made a very lenient sentence
it was personal error institutional
error and that's why you saw this Ramona
should have been charged as a felony
instead of a misdemeanor and there was a
sentencing fall down to what well I
think the president was asked
specifically a question that would fit
what you're saying Jesse he was asked
would you back extreme betting for
anyone who wants to get a gun in the
United States he then ran away from the
question but what you're saying is we
need to extremely vet these people to
make sure mistakes aren't made and to
make sure people who are mentally
incapacitated or extreme but others fail
excuse me we don't but the big argument
in gun control in this country is about
universal background checks so we do not
have even close to extreme betting as
President Obama said we need a right to
life argument here which is to say you
should be able to walk the streets and
feel safe in your church without the
thought that oh my god there's so many
guns anybody could put more guns in the
school more guns in the church more guns
at the Vegas concert more guns
everywhere you guys and Kimberly we're
probably going to find out that the FBI
is having a hard time getting into his
phone yeah we do know that he was
texting to his mother-in-law and and to
his father so we will follow we find out
more but I'm imagining that basically
one of the things we're going to find is
that you have family members who know
that they are involved with a very
dangerous individual but what is their
recourse and how what are they supposed
to do in order to help prevent something
which is what Greg was talking to me gap
that actually would be something useful
to talk about not just on mental health
but also how do you incapacitate
somebody who has the wherewithal to do
it and if the family member is worried
that this feels like the only thing we
can do is after the fact but yeah but
they
specially for women and children I think
they have to report they have to stand
up and say you know what I'm gonna call
the police and the authorities you can
love and a family I know I know you
can't Scott should have been locked up
right you can't put them in if you can't
put them in prisons there has to be in
state-run facilities we have to start
thinking about this again it got a bad
rap but it's time all right